bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
au sommaire de ça vous regarde ce soit
la france est elle prête en cas de
deuxième vague le conseil scientifique
estime que la recrudescence de la
pandémie et je cite extrêmement probable
d'autant que l'immunité collective reste
faible dans l'hexagone deux pays ont
confiné certaines régions
l'allemagne et le portugal quelle est
notre stratégie pour éviter cela c'est
le thème de notre débat ce soir lui aura
vécu un confinement productif le
créateur du puy-du-fou qui s'est battu
pour la réouverture de son parc
d'attractions signe un brûlot contre la
gestion de la crise sanitaire le nouveau
monde est mort du coronavirus
explique-t-il dans son livre de coyron
définitivement ses relations avec
emmanuel macron avec qui discutent
régulièrement nous poserons la question
à philippe de villiers
notre invité ce soir enfin dans ma
journée à l'assemblée thomas des prix va
nous raconter comment une proposition de
loi qui vise à donner plus d'autonomie
aux directeurs d'école finira finalement
dans un placard voilà donc pour le
programme ça vous regarde ces partis est
axée vers n'oubliez pas on y va
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs merci d'avoir choisi lcp
il s'appelle hand ce cloud
il dirige la branche europe de l' oms
l'organisation mondiale de la santé et
ils tirent aujourd'hui la sonnette
d'alarmé conférence de presse diffusée
en ligne depuis copenhague écouté
pendant des semaines
j'ai évoqué le risque d'une résurgence
du virus au fur et à mesure que les pays
se dé confine dans plusieurs pays
d'europe
ce risque est maintenant devenu une
réalité voilà des cas qui repartent à la
hausse en europe et la menace d'une
deviennent deuxième vague qui se
rapproche alors sommes nous prêts à y
faire face
on va se poser la question tous les
trois ce soir sur ce plateau bonsoir
gerald kerzec merci d'être là
vous êtes médecin docteur kirneck les
téléspectateurs de tf1 lci vous
connaissent bien chroniqueur santé
surtout médecin urgentiste à
l'hôtel-dieu bonsoir agent est sans
merci a vous bienvenue vous êtes député
la république on marche des français
d'asie d'océanie et d'europe orientale
et médecin de profession je passe la
parole dans un instant est ce qu'on est
prêt est ce qu'on ne l'ait pas celui qui
va nous planter le décor pour commencer
sur cette poussée alarmante de corona
c'était comme si j'ai bien compris tout
de suite
[Musique]
bonjour mesdames un bonjour docteur un
bon soir stéphane si j'ai bien compris
ce soir si j'ai bien compris myriam va
peut-être falloir penser à refaire votre
stock de pâtes et de pq quoi voilà
imagine qu'il vous reste deux ou trois
paquets de coquillettes peut-être
quelques rouleaux de pardon de
l'intéressé pas tout nouveau décor
papier toilette
oui mais s'il ya un rebond l'épidémie
est ce que ce sera suffisant myriam aaa
mais parce qu'on peut être maintenant on
a vu qu'on a l'expérience sur l'épidémie
on sait que comme le gouvernement on est
préparé on sait que le produit qui va
manquer le cadre de confinement c'est la
farine donc est-ce que vous avez des
stocks de farine par exemple alors c'est
gentil de faire l'inventaire de mes
placards je me soucie de vous mais
pourquoi qu'est ce qui vous rend si
alarmiste en sais pas peut-être que
c'est une déformation professionnelle
vous savez demandé au docteur qui passe
à la télé et rennes 27 chaînes sur la
tnt
donc si on dramatise pas un peu son
propos qu'est ce qui se passe les gens
s'ennuient isap mais rassurez vous quand
je tiens des propos anxiogènes
c'est toujours dans le respect de la
déontologie n'a pour l'instant c'est pas
si flagrant dites-donc myriam la vue ou
vous avez de la chance que j'ai pas de
carte de presse un sinon je voulais vous
la brandir est sous le nez parce que il
ya quand même des défaites doit se dire
que le gouvernement envisage
sérieusement l'hypothèse d'un rebond de
l'épidémie d'ailleurs c'est pas étonnant
puisque lundi le conseil scientifique a
déclaré je cite alors je vais vous lire
une intensification de la circulation du
virus dans l'hémisphère nord
on y est à une échéance plus ou moins
lointaine c'est un peu flou mais la
conclusion dit tout ça c'est extrêmement
probable
donc quand on est extrêmement probable
ça veut dire qu'on serait extrêmement
étonné s'il y avait pas un rebond
d'épidémie voilà mais là vous exagérez
peut-être c'est que si un rebond ça veut
pas forcément dire car confinement du
pays alalala myriam vous allez encore
obligé à tenir des propos anxiogènes
voyez bien que ce n'est pas de gaieté de
coeur mais leur confinement il a déjà
commencé alors bien sûr pas en france ou
plutôt pas encore en france
mais ce qui est sûr c'est qu'elle de là
plusieurs pays qui ont connu des rebonds
alors bien sûr les états unis venaient
sans doute entendu parler
trente cinq mille cas ben oui hier ou
avant-hier son cas un record depuis
avril donc a pas un vrai de confinement
mais voyez regarde les autorités on voit
le gouverneur jobs
greg abbott pardon qui recommande aux
habitants du texas de style comme donc
rester chez eux
il ya d'autres pays qui sont concernés
par des confirmands partiel
une haie à l'un des plus proches de nous
des pays européens comme l'allemagne le
portugais alors voyez ça c'est quand
même des pays qui ont été montrés en
exemple vraiment su contenir mieux que
les autres l'épidémie
et puis je ne veux bien sûr pas être
anxiogène mais il se trouve que quand
même ils ont été si l'on suit bien un
rebond qu'ils ont dû procéder à leur
confinement notamment en allemagne dans
le nord-ouest de l'allemagne qui a une
vie qui s'appelle buteur ce lot on va
voir quelques images
donc voyez là il y avait une personne
qui sont confinés en or amènent de la
nourriture dont myriam derrière la
grille voilà c'est ça le confinement
voyez vous en 10 derrière des grilles
bah oui bien sûr donc vous avez quand
même un intérêt à vérifier votre stock
de pat waid je suis alarmiste on a va
bien et tout et au portugal parce que ça
c'est très impressionnant effectivement
des grillages ça se passe comment
portugal au portugal c'est un peu plus
souple mais c'est dans la région de
lisbonne et villes limitrophes bas il ya
interdiction de rassemblement de plus de
10 personnes
on ferme les bars et les terrasses à
partir de 20h et puis interdiction de
l'alcool dans l'espace public dont ça
veut dire finie la fête pour l'église
bois est en fête alors vous savez que je
ne veux surtout pas vous inquiéter je
vous le dis depuis le début mais
j'espère quand même que vous n'habitez
pas trop près du canal saint martin à
paris
myriam ça va pas très loin mais bon pas
tout serait donc du monde a vu ces
images donc on va aller regarder la fête
de la musique au bord du canal
saint-martin avouer que ya eu quand même
un léger léger léger relâchement des
règles de distanciation sociale donc
voyez c'est un peu pour ça que je
m'inquiète un je veux pas vous prendre
par les sentiments mais ça fait quoi ça
fait deux jours que je suis revenu en
studio je suis contente oui si je suis
très content qu'on soit tous ensemble et
quand je vois ces images là je
m'inquiète un peu je me dis que je vais
pas tarder est retourné dans mon cas jbe
pour faire des papiers tout seul d'abord
mon ordinateur je vous garde je vous
garde auprès de moi merci stéphane
breton que doit alors deuxième vague
qu'elle deuxième vague des jamais mais
sur la deuxième vague gérald québec on a
l'impression que maintenant c'est plutôt
consensuelle en tout cas il ya beaucoup
plus d'experts scientifiques
infectiologues et épidémiologistes qui
vous disent 'elle est probable voire
extrêmement probable cette deuxième
vague en tout cas au bout de l'épidémie
est plutôt moins d'experts pour vous
dire le contraire
le virus il a pas disparu d'air au
passage en médecine quand on veut pas
inquiéter quelqu'un
on lui dit surtout pas ne vous inquiétez
pas parce que là c'est le meilleur moyen
de s'inquiéter dans cette deuxième vague
elle va arriver dans le sens où le virus
est toujours présent mais après c'est
l'intensité de la vague
oui si vous avez quelque chose vous
pouvez gérer un peu comme un incendie
que vous contenait des petits foyers à
chaque fois qu'il ya foyer ou mettez un
seau d'eau puis on a un deuxième qui est
à côté vous remettez un seau d'eau et
que les choses restent comme ça ça pose
pas de problème va pas flamber
exactement en revanche si vous ne
contrôlez plus parce que elle s'auto
suffit pas vous avez pris le foyer un
peu trop tardivement et que ça a pris
des proportions beaucoup plus
importantes on voit bien que ça ne va
pas suffire et c'est tout l'enjeu de ces
maisons qui sait à quel moment on va
perdre le contrôle et tout l'enjeu c'est
de ne pas perdre le contrôle et de
suivre à la trace les foyers qui
s'allument jeu reprend quand même les
mots du conseil scientifique que
stéphane a cité il parle de forte
recrudescence forte recrudescence de
l'épidémie comme étant je suis
extrêmement probable
là c'est pas le petit feu ou la
vaguelette non forte recrudescence je ne
sais pas en quoi que sur quels
indicateurs ils peuvent dire fort où il
aurait dit faible ou moyenne ou me
dirigeants syriens on les connaît pas
les indicateurs je crois surtout qu'il
vise à nous alerter sur le fait qu'il
faut être prêt et le ministre de la
santé je crois qu'une conférence de
presse aujourd'hui pour expliquer en
quoi certains hôpitaux où j'espère tous
d'ailleurs son prêt et puis mon comme
citoyenne j'aimerais bien m'assurer là
je suis moins je vois moi les choses
s'organisent et que nos entreprises sont
prêtes que nos écoles sont prêtes que
nos universités sont prêtes que nos
commerçants sont prêts avec des stocks
une organisation un référent pandémie
fin il ya tout un tas de choses à mettre
en oeuvre qui permet l'instant au petit
feu au moyen feu et on disparaît jamais
les écoles même si effectivement elle
maintienne l'effort est elle se des
confits nains ou novell je retourne lui
ai parlé il ya l'adaptation la situation
actuelle et qu'ensuite il ya une
anticipation ça ne nous empêche pas de
nous préparer à ce qui pourrait être le
futur est là il est raisonnable de
prendre une hypothèse anxiogène
peut-être comme vous l'évoquez de façon
à pouvoir affronter n'importe quelle
taille de feu c'est ça surtout un coût
et des milthon jalkh avec les images sur
le canal saint martin le danger s'est
passé du tout c'est à dire on était tous
confinés on était chez soi etc ou rien
et donc c'est bascule et ça quand on
voit les images là
de la musique on se dit bon bain les
gens ça y est le virus il me derrière il
est derrière eux il est derrière nous
alors ça c'est faux la réalité c'est que
le virus continue à circuler le gros de
l'épidémie est passé
mais le virus est toujours présent et
donc le danger c'est justement de ne pas
passer à ce rien rien en termes de
mesures politiques n'ont pas été assez
dur avec ses images non aurait dû
davantage condamner les comportements et
faire expliquer les choses et surtout
faut donner des mesures barrières qui
soit acceptable et nabeul et durable sur
le long terme
en belgique la première ministre a fait
une allocution à la vraiment d'un air de
bien grave dénoncée les fêtes qui avait
eu lieu à bruxelles du même genre en
disant que c'était inacceptable qui a
suscité de la colère de la population
donc il était vraiment très faire
beaucoup plus ferme qu'en france elle
n'a pas du tout été condamné je suis pas
tout à fait d'accord parce que si les
gens n'ont pas fait c'est qu'ils n'ont
pas compris pourquoi c'est pas en
condamnant qu'on va leur faire
comprendre
donc il vaut mieux expliquer revenir à
aux bases de revenir à l'essentiel en
rappelant le virus circule mais le
risque c'est d'être tous est un petit
peu en décalage avec la réalité de
l'épidémie de son il ya toujours un
décalage entre le moment où une personne
circulation plus intense quelque part un
moment s'en aperçoit c'est le prof de
cette fille démis donc il faut savoir
être prêt à tout moment et je pense
qu'il vaut mieux revenir plus tôt que
lors d'un discours dramatisant très
inquiétant médias ou que vous l'avez au
début mais ce que le gouvernement est
peut-être à juste titre a fait peur à
essayer véritablement voilà l'enduro du
bien c'est sûr les mêmes mais
aujourd'hui dans un autre schéma est là
l'idée serveur se autre éventualité
on n'est pas dans un schéma faire peur
mais soyez responsable dans le schéma
sortait pour consommer sortait pour
relancer l'économie c'est possible mais
ce qui est possible en prenant des
précautions
c'est juste ça qu'il faut rappeler on
doit respecter les barrières et il
pensait pour nous et pour nos proches à
l'argile
je voudrais qu'on continue à discuter ce
qu on est prêt et puis surtout est ce
que ces saisonniers ou parce que là on a
une vraie question mais je voudrais
qu'on écoute karine lacombe
karine lacombe infectiologue à l'hôpital
saint-antoine qui était auditionné dans
le cadre de la commission d enquête
parlementaire ce matin si nous devions
avoir une deuxième vague je pense
qu'avec les outils qui ont été mis en
place en termes de dépistage d'isolement
des personnes contactent on ne devrait
pas connaître l'ampleur d'une deuxième
vague tel qu'on l'a vécu avec la
première vague avec ce qu'on a mis en
place
qu'est ce qu'on a mis en place qui nous
permettrait d'avoir comme elle dit karim
lacombe vous êtes d'accord avec elle une
deuxième vague moindre taille repéré
tester et sans repères en testant en
remontant la chaîne donc elle parle
notamment de ses équipes d'assurance
maladie qui sont là pour aller traquer
remonter le filet pour aller chercher
des foyers à maxima parce que on
n'attend pas de retour si on notera les
fameuses frégates d'ange gardien un vrai
est un vrai problème qu'on n'ait pas de
retour notamment l'assurance maladie ou
des agences régionales de santé parce
que ça permettrait de savoir où sont ses
foyers précisément alors on sait on voit
qu'il ya les abattoirs par exemple on
voit quelle est la part des foyers
familiaux
ça c'est encore quelque chose et avec un
gros point d'interrogation quelle est la
part des foyers de personnes âgées les
ehpad en particulier on sait qu'en
allemagne par exemple il ya des endroits
comme les abattoirs qui sont identifiés
et donc du coup ça permet de faire des
tests un peu de manière préventive ce
comice de la santé vient d'annoncer
d'ailleurs olivier ferrand j'allais dire
iméo tard que jamais j'ai passé quelques
uns la réponse mais séquelles du
graffiti vous avez dit on est prêts on
peut faire 700 mille tests c'est là le
ce qu'il faut en fait je crois comme en
fait 250 morts
c'est simplement faire mon cas quand
j'ai si je me trompe pas ce que c'est
parce qu'on n'a pas besoin de plus on
teste tout ce qu'ils soient ont des
symptômes 60 contact de symptômes et en
faisant tout ça on arrive à seulement on
n'a pas besoin des choses il est là elle
a passé un stade supplémentaire c'est ce
qu'a annoncé olivier ferrand avec ces
fameux tests un peu de manière aléatoire
qu'on demande depuis plusieurs semaines
pour ne pas dire plusieurs mois en
disant il faut qu'on est née une idée
précise de ce qui se passe sur le
territoire et points avant une idée
territoire alors dû du monde il parle de
clusters dormant c'est à dire tout
simplement des gens craquent qui sont
contaminés qui ne savent pas donc les
gens qui dansent et peut-être plus comme
un oui il faut tester pour moi
actuellement on teste les gens même
temps où les contacts là il faut tester
au hasard sur terry n'est ni comment
elles entendent y avoir des galloires
lundi jour de la fête de la musique on a
vu ces images plutôt que de dire cela
monte ou au contraire essayer de le
cogner dessus pourquoi on n'en voit pas
une espèce de tan tan guitoune avec
tests possibles mais bien sûr un vin et
on irait se faire tester ce trait de
manière aléatoire ce qui permettrait ces
jeunes qui sont en bonne santé à priori
donc ils sont asymptomatiques mais
potentiellement contaminés que ça veut
dire ça vient d'un training avec les
tests pqr
cavillon et on y suit on fait quoi on a
on incite les gens les pagnes sont les
coordonnées et on incite les gens les
parcs on se posait la question anne
hidalgo voulait rouvrir ministre voulait
pas être cité
mais il faut les rouvrir et sur ses
parcs publics il faut aller proposer des
centres de dépistage c'est l'épidémie du
sida dans les années 80 c'était ça
c'était à la fois de la prévention et du
dépistage qui était proposé on pourrait
très bien faire la même chose et ça
pourrait être une réponse au milieu de
la nuit puisque gdc j'ai des collègues
parlementaires qu'ils ont parlé de ça je
vais vous dire qu'en corée par exemple
les résurgences qu'on avait apparaissent
c'est amusant de voir que dans le
vocabulaire des médias on parle de
deuxième vague en asie alors ce sont des
foyers et non les appels foyer chez nous
mais c'est le même principe encore et
c'est le milieu de la nuit
essentiellement au japon c'est mieux de
la nuit pardon c'est japon exactement
donc
et là aussi on pourrait tout à fait
proposer de la même façon des taux reste
aléatoire au volant expliquez-nous ce
qui va se passer dans les semaines à
venir il va y avoir donc c'est barnum
c'est ça pour passer enfin à quoi 700
mille tests on est ado c'est pas voir m
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui les la ville qui
se trouvait avec des tests sur les bras
la réactiver les propositions les bars
mais un gros con fait le new york times
a faim il parle de clusters d'ormeaux et
il parle de l'assurance maladie qui va
envoyer notamment dans des zones un peu
à risque comme quand vous avez un
dépistage une mammographie vous recevez
à partir de 50 ans vous recevez un bon
pour les vous faire tester
là ça sera la même chose
l'assurance-maladie enverra un bon pour
aller se faire tester
on n'est pas du tout sûr des dépistages
aléatoire lors de paris pour être précis
les bandes on parle
olivier v rendant dans le monde
aujourd'hui ce sont pour les tests
sérologiques t'es pas de bêtises c'est
pas des têtes de bétail à les deux de
virologie qui assure tous les tests
virologiques les rôles masque encore une
fois les tests sérologiques j'allais
dire c'est pas très important on est
après la bataille les tests sérologiques
c'est est ce que vous avez eu la maladie
ne venaient plus contaminant or tout
l'enjeu actuellement c'est d'aller
chercher des clusters dormons de gens
contaminés sur les véritables cordiale
et cr une véritable campagne de
mobilisation va maintenant si fier sur
the reasons synthèse autrement ce qu'a
dit mr c'est sur certaines zones
géographiques
j'imagine dans des zones une densité de
mais ont testé un million deux cent
mille personnes en ile de france
je suis d'autant qu'il s'accapare turbo
ya un rassemblement de personnes au
cours de suffisamment de replonger c'est
là qu'il faudra probablement je ne suis
pas un des petits papiers du ministre
pour savoir où donc les quand on voit
les faibles un nombre donné l'argent
soit 10 pour arriver à un million deux
cent mille tests en ait 200 experts
quand il n'est pas obligatoire le test
pap
je pense que l'objectif n'est pas
chiffrée l'objectif qui est une
efficacité donc à partir de man nous
avons des zones où les gens se
rassemblaient selon temps ensemble
il faut pouvoir mettre à 10% test faire
réagir en lisant sur les bunds invalides
c'est auprès de l'assemblée
le fonds sera l'hémicycle parce qu'on
est bien dans ses montées ensemble
si les plages à des gens car il en est
un qui ne vont pas vouloir se faire
tester mais il ya plein de gens qui
seraient intéressés pour avoir cette
possibilité de et après on va trouver un
certain nombre de pourcentage alors
c'est là où il faut que les données sont
vues soit publié parce que si la
rentabilité du test est proche de zéro
grâce à ses rennes allait déployer sur
tout le territoire un gros dispositif et
les caméras thermiques
pourquoi on l'avait dash pas dans les
faits on peut on il ya des gens qui sont
asymptomatiques et qui n'ont absolument
aucune fièvre alors qu'ils ont et sont
porteurs du virus donc c 'est on
pourrait en dépister quelques-uns s'agit
pas que c'était d'être mis en place des
contrôles et les caméras thermiques sont
en train d'être mis en place dans les
aéroports
après c'est vrai que c'est pas 100%
c'est un peu comme avec une épuisette
c'est en fonction des mailles du filet
ou à les attraper des petites choses des
grosses choses là vous allez attraper
des gens qui vont avoir la température
d'autres gens n'auront pas de fièvre et
seront porteurs quand même mais c'est
toujours mieux que rien ça rassure la
population aussi mais ces voiliers c'est
nous on appelle ça en analyse systémique
il ya un système il ya toute une chaîne
bien il faut plusieurs points de
contrôle et c'est plusieurs points de
contrôle vont faire qu'on va pouvoir
avoir le maximum de tests qui vont
revenir à la fin positive parce que si
vous avez la possibilité par l'assurance
maladie chez vous au laboratoire chez
votre médecin traitant pourquoi pas dans
votre entreprise et pourquoi pas dans un
parc etc etc en plus il ya des caméras
thermiques parce que vous prenez un vol
pour les jeunes c'est où
eh bien ce sont autant de chances
d'avoir un test positif c'est ça c'est
pour la dimension du test tester plus
massivement on en est pas là aujourd'hui
on entend les objectifs du ministre delà
de la santé une fois qu'on a fait les
tests il faut tracer et là encore on se
dit mais ça voilà où on en est sa a
pas l'air de fonctionner on a parlé des
anges gardiens d'assurance maladie là on
a regardé les chiffres de ce top
qu'ovide stop qu'ovide le nombre de
notifications sur les 1 millions
d'applications téléchargées est ce que
voulait le connais j'ai eu ce 0 quand
même la descente de croix dont les 14 14
en tout 14 mai non mais comment on va
pouvoir saisir ça fonctionnerait pas les
outils quand on a les tests puisque
maintenant on les a pour aller tracer
les gens elle les avait retirées
remontée des chaînes de jeu originale
diffusée au québec si je crois qu'il
faut un ensemble d'outils qui nous
permette de l'objectif c'est de repérer
le plus vite le plus tôt possible ceux
qui sont porteurs pour pouvoir leur dire
restez chez vous et dites nous avec qui
vous avez vous des objectifs pour les
instants les eaux les moyens pour les
mettre à l'heure les moyens il y en a
beaucoup on a parlé de tous les outils
qu'on a de dépistage par test maintenant
on a aussi en plus le fait de remonter
de tracé c'est un outil je rappelle
favorable au personnel je voudrais comme
souligné qu'au moment de la des tout
premiers cas aux contamines montjoie en
savoie c'est cet outil de traçage qui
nous a permis très très vite de
circonscrire de comprendre remonter ce
qui s'était passé donc on sait qu'on a
un outil efficace
maintenant c'était un foyer particulier
x l'échelle du territoire
est ce que tous ces équipes sont
efficaces moi j'ai pas lu de donner
effectivement qui nous permettent de
nous d'avoir un jugement d'avoir un
retour d'expérience lettre il faudra
fait et ça c'est un problème il faut que
rapidement quasiment en temps réel y ait
des données qui nous disent voilà on a
réussi à attraper tant de cas et c'est
ça fonctionne ou ça fonctionne pas mais
elles regagnaient
liddell et télécharger cette fois plus
en allemagne s'était largement stocco
vie d'un ses noces et une autre va
lancer une autre application mais stop
cowitz est probablement arrivé trop tard
on sait très bien que les gens en
allemagne et 50 ans plus tard que chez
nous oui différentes aussi bien
différencier l'ile-de-france du reste de
la france pourquoi parce que l'île de
france et les transports en commun
énormément de contacts etc
et je pense que stock co vide peut
fonctionner sur ces endroits là en
revanche en province qu est-ce qui va
fonctionner mais c'est le médecin
traitant
c'est l'entreprise c'est les endroits où
il ya des rassemblements parce que les
gens se connaissent pas ce que le
médecin traitant
quand il a repéré un patient et bien il
va réussir à le convaincre il va
remonter la chaîne de contamination et
c'est ce qui est pas possible quand vous
avez pris le métro vous avez croisé je
ne sais combien de personnes et là dans
le métro c'est soit stock co vide soit
surtout les mesures barrières qu'il faut
répéter inlassablement alors c'est pas
la peine d'arriver des gants se
désinfecter toutes les deux minutes etc
mais tout simplement le masque quand on
est dans un univers clos se laver les
mains avant et après et se tenir à
distance ses trois mesures sans moi
j'appelle ça les 3 mg l lemmens les lave
le masque on le porte en univers clos et
on est à un mètre de distance au minimum
c3m c'est quand même pas sorcier à
appliquer et c'est ça qui va bientôt
l'un d'eux ce qui va passer cinq minutes
au terme vous alles québec avec un peu
de recul maintenant vous pensez qu'on
pouvait on aurait pu faire mieux
qu'est ce qui a été fait moi je pense
qu'on aurait pu faire mieux avec ce qui
a été fait notamment sur les basques et
un volet qu on a complètement passé sous
silence sont les capacités hospitalières
là on est bien qu est-ce qu assez testé
à c est ensuite allé bien sûr on fait
mieux parce que bon on a été tous pris
de court enfin gea l'italie était pris
de court l'europe été pris de court
l'allemagne un peu moins mais enfin
globalement maintenant on a un peu
compris les mesures barrières là aussi
c'est quand même assez fondamental parce
que ça va être de la prévention donc ça
va éviter de se retrouver avec un foyer
explosif en france c'est parti de
mulhouse
c'est parti de cette église évangéliste
ou ayez toutes les conditions étaient
réunies
donc les mesures barrières et
participants qui a essaimé un peu
l'épidémie ça on va plus recommencer car
quand vous entendez la liaison d'abord
les leaders de l'opposition et eric
ciotti qui était assez veulent peuvent
d'ailleurs y'a pas longtemps ici et
design nous évidemment qu'on aurait fait
mieux on enfin beaucoup de gens de
l'opposition ce discours là ça vous vie
mais après il est conscient il ya des
postures politiques
ce que je regarde c'est que médicalement
on ferait mieux actuellement par le
repérage les mesures d'un
l'addiction et les mesures barrières
mesure d'interdiction du monde de la
nuit des boîtes de nuit par exemple ça
va éviter la propagation des grands
rassemblements comme mulhouse moscou ne
serait aujourd'hui volet hospitalier
capital or aujourd'hui est-ce que à
l'hôpital on est capable d'encaisser
lâchant que le ministre a indiqué
aujourd'hui douze mille lits de
réanimation à l'hôpital mais on n'est
pas plus capable en nature 5000 lits a
toujours eu les hôpitaux de proximité
ils sont fermés ils ont pas rouvert
l'hôpital de lisieux avait un service
qu'ovide de médecine qui a été fermé le
service co vide et a fermé mais les
livres ont fermé faute de recrutement de
médecins etc
donc on voit bien que la machine
administrative et quand même lui des
années fait qu on a un nombre de lits on
a six lits pour 1000 habitants en france
l'allemagne et un plus de 8 la corée qui
a eu des résultats assez remarquable au
quai de tests etc
mais en capacité hospitalière ils sont à
plus du double or on voit bien que ce
volant de sécurité si jamais on a des
malades qui arrivent il faut qu'on a un
volant de sécurité pour prier ne va pas
fermer définitivement les fabrice koffy
disons les enfermer parce que pour
l'instant il ya un flou mais ce service
à lisieux je vous prends cet exemple il
ya plein d'exemples en france qui est
qui devrait être un service de médecine
normal et bien la chance régionale de
santé avait prévu de le fermer faute de
recrutement médical
ils ont fermé définitivement les lie
donc on voit bien que si jamais on avait
besoin de capacités hospitalières et 20
milliards et après je vous donne la
parole et se termine juste côté côté
santé les 6 milliards annoncés
aujourd'hui c'est suffisant ou pas j'ai
pris mes petits calculs ce que pour
faire face à une éventuelle deuxième
vague importante il faudra aussi j'ai
pris ma calculette et j'ai fait 300
euros de revalorisation mensuel pour les
infirmières les aides soignants pour
deux millions de personnes qui
travaillent dans le secteur de la santé
2 millions multiplié par 300 euros net
par mois multiplié par douze mois il
faudrait déjà le double de 2,6 milliards
donc on voit bien que il va y avoir une
revalorisation nécessaire mais pas
suffisante et c'est pas qu'une histoire
de moyens aussi on a beaucoup parlé de
gouvernance on a beaucoup parlé d'
acteurs de proximité ce qui a fonctionné
c'est que les anesthésistes réanimateurs
ont poussé les murs ont transformé les
salles de réveil ont un moment donné dit
au directeur on a besoin de temps litan
de respirateurs et senna on s'est
organisé à l'hôpital et c'est ce qu'on
pouvait plus faire depuis des années et
on voit bien que chassé le naturel il
revient au galop
la gouvernance et les directeurs
d'hôpitaux leur tableur excel les
réductions de budget c'est personnel
elles reviennent au galop à john t
pour répondre aux deux pères qui relègue
au fond on n'est pas complètement prêt
et en plus les moyens sur la table pour
l'hôpital ne sont pas suffisants je
trouve que c'est presque faire une
insulte à l'hôpital veut dire qu'on
n'est pas complètement prêt on ne peut
pas du jour au lendemain de transformer
l'hôpital il a on connaît ses limites
ses difficultés
on est en train d'y travailler mais en
tout cas s'il devait y avoir une
augmentation du nombre de cas avec une
nécessité d'hospitaliser plus de monde
peut-être pas dans les mêmes proportions
aujourd'hui nous avons vu que l'hôpital
avait su y faire face et je suis
certaine
il faut ré féliciter nos soignants
pardon ne seraient capables il a tenu
parce qu on a confiné tout le monde il a
tenu parce qu'on n'a pas soigné les
autres mana mais il a tenu parce que les
malades avec un cancer qui ont eu trois
mois de retard dans la vue et quelques
anciens et à progresser je vais te
positiver c'est quand je vais être
positif oui mais je dis pas que c'est
optimale je suis pas entraîné cette
optimale je dis qu'on est tenu et qu'il
faut pas faire croire aux gens qu'ils
seront pas soigné qui seront pas traités
qu'ils aient le covin d'autre chose ça
c'est faux ils seront traités sont
soignés quelle que soit la pathologie
qui l'ont dans des conditions qui sont
peut-être parfois un peu acrobatique
on est en train d'y travailler le ségur
de la santé là pour ça un chiffre a été
avancé milliard vous l'avez n'y a pas
que les chiffres il ya effectivement la
gouvernance qui a été longtemps rappelez
moi personnellement j'espère vivement
qu'on sera finement travaillé sur cette
gouvernance et rebondir capitaliser sur
l'agilité qu'on a su développer pendant
laquelle je voudrais qu'on termine ce
débat par une question on parle de la
deuxième vague nous parle de sa taille
la question c'est quand quand cette
deuxième vague c'est la question de la
saisonnalité de ce coronavirus on va
écouter didier raoul s'exprimer sur le
sujet longtemps et c'était hier à
l'assemblée nation l'hémisphère sud à
une inversion des saisons donc l'hiver
c'est maintenant dans l'hémisphère sud
et comme la nouvelle zélande et à une
latitude qui est la même que la nôtre
sur l'hémisphère sud
et bien si il y à une épidémie de
coronavirus actuellement en nouvelle
zélande qui débute on peut se dire mon
dieu il est bien possible que nous
emmenons reprenions et qu'elle devienne
saisonnière l'année prochaine pendant la
saison froide
après avoir dit qu'il n'y aurait pas de
deuxième vague cette fois ci le
professeur dédi raout explique il ne
sait pas mais que c'est possible et que
la nouvelle zélande sera un bon
éducateur indicateurs
je pense que professeur n'était pas du
tout au courant c'est ma circonscription
aller le connais très bien la nouvelle
zélande qu'effectivement très bien géré
la situation qui s'est notamment
beaucoup confinés et isolés qui est
sorti du confinement maintenant ils ont
eu deux cas effectivement ils
s'attendaient vraiment il avait annoncé
la prémisse à vannes on sait qu'il ya
vait disparition du virus sont
extrêmement content et je comprends ça
rejoint le souci des cachets mais en
l'occurrence les deux cas qui sont
arrivées ce sont deux femmes qui
venaient d'europe
décosse et qui sont venus rendre visite
à de la famille en nouvelle zélande donc
vous dites quoi départ mais j'ai acheté
lorsque je dis je dis simplement que
l'exemple de la nouvelle zélande qui a
choisi est très mal choisi mais ce
qu'ils disent il faut regarder il n'est
pas qu'il ya une deuxième vague ou
première vague dans l'hémisphère il
regarde ce qu'il faut il faut regarder
dans l'autre hémisphère qui sont
inversés en termes de saisonnalité ce
qui me semble assez logique ils sont pas
partis du même point non plus dans le
sud
il faut regarder le comportement du
virus en hiver et il est très probable
que l'hiver prochain on aura encore il
va falloir apprendre à vivre avec le
coronavirus alors après si c'est vivre
avec un virus qu'on arrive à calmer
qu'on arrive à tenir encore une fois
comme un feu qui couve et a tout de
suite le cirque en grippe ça pose pas de
problème au passage les mesures
barrières là le masque de lavage des
mains et ses actions des mesures que
nous médecins on répète à longueur
d'année ça éviterait des milliers de
morts pour la grippe
ça éviterait éviterait les gars me
castelli évitera les normes aimant
d'épidémie donc finalement on pourrait
même si elle couronne à virus mais que
ces mesures barrières ça va permettre
d'éviter beaucoup de morts dus
coronavirus la pathologie noté de
questions encore sur ces questions de
température il ya des pays comme le
brésil où il fait chaud quand même je
pense où le virus circule fortement
c'est pas la température d'abord ce sont
les uv et qui détruisent ce virus par la
température la température
il faut plus de 60 degrés pendant quatre
minutes in vitro donc on voit que il
faudrait vraiment une phase très très
très chaud c'est même impossible donc
c'est plutôt le rayonnement uv mais
c'est la saisonnalité
en revanche le bon argument c'est de
dire quand il fait chaud on vit dehors
et quand on vit dehors ce ne sont pas
les conditions propices pour pouvoir
avoir le virus qui se qui se multiplient
et qui se passe d'un individu à l'autre
individu à une question je sais que les
temps il faut que vous étiez venu il y
avait la crise à venise vous disais ah
ben moi j'irais bien à venise malgré
tout si tu avais pas ce confinement mais
est-ce que vous partiez en vacances à
l'étranger cet été parce que si ça
redémarre et qu'on est bloqué alors il
ya deux raisons sur le plan sanitaire ya
vraiment des pays dans lesquels je les y
gérait sans hésiter ça c'est certain en
revanche foudre est sûre de pouvoir
revenir et aussi la difficulté finement
dans un pays qu'il avait dans ses
projets graphiques pas seulement un pays
entier mais une leçon de géographie
comme le fait l'allemagne sur une petite
zone puisque dans une zone qui re
confiné je pourrais me retrouver bloqué
quatre équipes d'être bloquée parce que
le virus ne sont pas les grillages en
c'est bien mais ça me gênerait beaucoup
plus d'être bloqué quelque part que de
penser un risque malgré tout c'est un
risque
possibilité de je crois que s'éteigne
alors partez à lisbonne cet été vous
pouvez rester bloqués non c'est pas le
virus xbox police dans une zone minée
effet si je peux dans un quartier de
lisbonne ou brutalement effectivement
une résurgence et puis il décide pendant
deux semaines trois semaines 400 alors
pour terminer je vais pas le conseil du
docteur qui résultait de la députée
s'est testé tester allez vous faire
tenir mais le conseil pour les
spectateurs ils nous regardent ces
gestes bassine à vendre on aime encore
une fois et c'est pas un virus qui vous
sautent dessus si un virus voilà et tout
devrait bien se passer faut pas être
alarmiste faut pas être angélique non
plus et on va voir ce qui se passe dans
les prochains jours n'a eu les mains
sous les mains porter un masque est
porté à l'ex sang l'enlever le remet
tout le temps parce que ça c'est
vraiment super aussi merci merci à tous
les deux d'avoir participé à ce débat va
parler à présent d'un livre les gaulois
réfractaires demande des comptes au
nouveau monde chez fayard tout philippe
de villiers dans ce titre 150 pages au
vitriol écrites pendant le confinement
les oreilles des manuels macro ont dû
siffler en le lead en avant d'accueillir
philippe de villiers retour sur cette
relation aussi complexe qu'un probable
entre le président et le vicomte vendéen
ahmed tazir emmanuel macron dans l'arène
du puy du fou aux commandes d'un char
tout sourire aux côtés de philippe de
villiers
les images des deux hommes ensemble sont
rares nous sommes à l'été 2016
le créateur du puy-du-fou sur ses terres
accueillent celui qui n'est alors que
ministre de l'économie et bientôt
candidat à l'elysée le vicomte de
villiers et héritier de la droite
souverainiste conservatrice emmanuel
macron est plutôt libérale une relation
amicale est pourtant né même si
politiquement
tout les oppose mais ça n'empêche pas de
discuter avec lui d'avoir une relation
courtoise et est toujours content de le
croiser la même vision des choses
emmanuel macron devenu président c'est
amitiés sulfureuses ne semble pas
inquiéter dans les rangs de la majorité
heureusement que vous n'êtes pas ami
qu'avec les gens qui partagent toutes
vos idées finances très triste je serai
secteur moi qui suis un maquereau nist
qui ne renie pas être un maquereau nist
je pense qu'effectivement nous sommes
justement sur cette définition des
macros nice je pense qu'on peut aimer
l'écologie sans être sectaire on peut
être libéral sans être capitaliste on
peut aussi sur sept points sur ce ils
sont très précises ml tradition sans
être conservateur on peut être patriote
sans être nationaliste
comment se fait-il que philippe de
villiers s'entendent si bien avec
emmanuel macron dans l'opposition on se
pose des questions
est-ce que son intérêt à lui c'est de
nuire à la droite en tout cas c'est sa
volonté on a bien le sentiment que c'est
lui ou l'extrême droite ou l'extrême
gauche et qu'il a envie de faire le
ménage autour pour que le chemin de
willeman de lys wali soit complètement
ouvert donc ça a été un peu gênant comme
cette histoire du puy du fou pendant le
déconfinement avec une sorte d' un
sentiment qu'il y avait une forme de
passe-droit du coup pour pour philippe
de villiers et le puy du fou alors que
l'ensemble du monde de la culture lui
demeuré confiné bon eh oui à la suite de
l'intervention du président le parc du
puy du fou a réouvert l'on joint edouard
philippe préféré lui temporisé avant une
telle annonce emmanuel macron philippe
de villiers une lune de miel qui
pourrait bien prendre fin dans son
nouveau livre philippe de villiers et
riz dr macro et mister emmanuel il
raconte comment le président l'a charmée
avant de le décevoir
bonsoir philippe de villiers bonsoir et
merci d'être là ancien ministre
fondateur du puy du fou
bonsoir à fait logique ravi de vous
retrouver en challenge du quotidien
ledroit jeudi je me suis dit avec le
point l'eau d'opinion pardonnez-moi
chroniqueur économique question il a lu
le président de la république se livre à
ce que voulait renvoyer déjà ce coup là
parce que vous allez envoyer
alors je lui ai dédicacé pas savoir
comme faisait remarquer oui car de
mémoire en substance
shy'm annuel vous avez annoncé le 13
avril dernier
que vous souhaitiez vous réinventer et
voici mon petit banal de réinvention ma
trousse d'urgence faisant bon usage pour
que le pays ne roule pas là bim alors il
m'a pas répondu directement mais il a
utilisé des mots notamment l'un d'entre
eux sur le séparatisme qui était dans
mon livre et je m'arrêtais avant la
crise sanitaire séparatisme et je me
suis laissé dire qu'il avait qu'il avait
lu le livre voilà vous jouez limite vous
jouez un peu de cette amitié
on peut dire amitié cette relation mais
si si particulière attention vous
expliquer ce qui suscite on voit au delà
curiosité beaucoup de commentaires oui
pourquoi
bah tout simplement parce que les choses
sont beaucoup plus simple qu'il n'y
paraît en fait quand il était ministre
de l'économie
il a voulu venir au puy du fou
c'est pas un péché non c'est non il a
payé sa chambre et évolué et comment il
a été en contact avec vous pour ça donc
il voulait venir voir le puy du fou il a
passé un long moment avec brigitte et il
souhaitait avoir un longue échange avec
moi bon voilà on a eu un long échange
notamment sur la question de la france
et la mondialisation
je lui ai dit il faut vos prédécesseurs
ont adapté la france à la mondialisation
fera faire l' inverse
si vous êtes j'ai lu à l'époque il était
ministre de l'économie bon y avait peu
de chance à mes yeux qu'il fut élu bon
et ensuite en partant et m'a dit c'est
un fleuron français
c'est ce que je pensais mes 20 ans je
découvre quelque chose qui pour moi me
touche et vous pouvez compter sur tout
mais attention voilà je me sens plus
folle est comme on dit au volley au
point d'ailleurs de vous entendre
puisque il a rendu possible la
réouverture du ponant fou vous avez
entendu pierre dharréville député
communiste qui parle clairement de
faveur qu'est ce que vous répondez à ça
et le mal ne passe droit mais voilà il
est mal informé parce que a été ce qui
passait au conseil de défense c'est pas
seulement le plus fou mais 500
établissements culturels et si vous
interrogez certains présidents de
festival ils disent grâce au plus du
tout voilà et a eu évidemment aucun
aucun passe rassemblant ce que je
voulais dire c'est que emmanuel macron
il me connaît bien
il sait que je suis souverainiste que je
pas changé d'avis quand il a parlé de la
lèpre populaire je lui ai dit je suis
avec ma creissels juillet je suis
lépreux
populis et je me soigne pas donc les
choses sont claires mais alors qu'en
fait on a une double conversation et
emmanuel d'un côté
emmanuel macron au mr macron de l'autre
vous oscillez entre les deux un oui
alors le en fait ce qui me fera beaucoup
c'est que c'est un homme du nouveau
monde mais qui est capable de revenir à
l'ancien monde la preuve dans son
dernier sa dernière allocution et
parlent d'indépendance de souveraineté
de relocaliser en parler et donc il est
capable de faire des saltos avant de
faire des saltos arrière
je m'excuse est ce que vous le trouvez
sincère ou est ce que au fond c'est un
caméléon comme beaucoup d'hommes
politiques regardent ce que vous écrivez
j'ai mis du temps à comprendre ce qui se
cachait derrière des figures
chorégraphiques du en même temps macron
des villes
emmanuel deschamps il passe d'une rive à
l'autre et offre à ses amis dans
l'instant le témoignage une conviction
sincère je le crois capable d'empathie
pour moi et d'amitié pour cohn-bendit
en réalité le docteur macron écoute cohn
bendit et le mister emmanuel entend
villiers en gros il dit à tous ceux qui
veulent entendre qu'ils veulent entendre
quoi dans le temps il vient au puy du
fou en 2016
et là il me dit vous avez raison le
souverainisme ccdh à venir puis en le 4
mars 2018 dont kim d la lèpre populiste
donc la vie fait demi-tour avec la
souveraineté européenne cetera et puis
là dans l'inconnu le 17 mai dernier me
dit dans une conversation assez longue
où il dit il faut ouvrir on va faire
comme il peut et settat et là il ya un
désaccord avec son premier et me dit où
vous donne raison en fait sur la
question de la souveraineté la question
des frontières voilà donc le premier
ministre me dit vous disais que noir
philippe ce qu'ils avaient enduré 10 ans
étaient les craintes des plaintes
exactement
je comprenais pas j'avais eu edouard
philippe le 13 mai longuement 45 minutes
une conversation très serré parce qu'ils
me dit non non vous nourrirez pas non
plus que les stades non plus que rien et
je lui dis vous êtes sous vous êtes vous
êtes en train de provoquer la déchirure
des tissus conjonctifs de la france
industrieuse attention l économie
virtuelle va peut-être sortir l économie
connectés mais l'économie du gagne pain
elle va mourir
et quand j'ai le président que j'envoie
un message au président à emmanuel
macron et je le dis tous les nouveaux
gènes et générant un message en disant
ben voilà on assisterait bientôt à
l'enterrement les plus fous entre autres
et il n'est pas question est là on
convient de s'appeler le dimanche soir
il m'appelle et il me dit dans la
conversation
on va faire crever le pays
donc il est furieux et il m'a dit 'il
cher son risque pénal ravis de voir
philippe voilà ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire que alors survie de tous ses
recours en justice contre le premier
ministre il n'est pas le seul ministre
en cause mais ont eu des incidences
directes sur les décisions coulisses ça
veut dire là on était à l'assemblée donc
j'en profite
soul et moi j'étais parlementer un
certain temps et je suis un peu affolés
par l'évolution entre lajudie entre le
le précautionnisme que maintenant la
constitution qui fait qu'un maire quand
ils installent un panneau de basket ce
duo là qu'est ce qui va m'arriver et la
judiciarisation à l'américaine j'ai peur
que l'action publique soit paralysée
donc moi je ne suis pas un train de
rigoler quoi dé quoi sans ces recours en
justice
edouard quenu pour aider confie n'est
plus vite à mais j'en suis persuadé je
pense que si nos gouvernants n'était pas
traumatisé par le sang contaminé l
affaire fabius il aurait il aurait des
confiné beaucoup plus alors il était
parti pour puisque la carte rouge à
partir mais il fallait aller plus vite
et moi je pense que 20
encore une fois emmanuel macumba made in
là il n'y a pas de deuxième vague cet
été il ya peut-être une deuxième vague
évoqué tout à l'heure voilà à l'auteur à
l'automne mais sur le fond ses recours
qui se multiplient est-ce que c'est
dangereux pour vous commencez à peu
aller à les condamner
il ya une soif de coupable qu'il faut
dénoncer alors il ya vraiment deux
choses encore une fois je parle dans
cette enceinte de la représentation
nationale
il ya la grandeur et la noblesse de la
responsabilité politique pour les actes
politiques
et puis comme on n'est pas en union
soviétique il n'y a pas de faute pénale
collective donc à la responsabilité
individuelle intentionnel là c'est la
justice mais la justice ne peut juger
que les fautes intentionnelles et
individuelles attention à la confusion
entre la recherche de la justice et la
recherche de coupables parce qu'en fait
la recherche de coupables
ça aboutit au contraire de ce qu'on veut
nous on voudrait réformer actions de
l'état faire en sorte qu'elle soit plus
efficace et là judiciaire la
judiciarisation parfois peut conduire à
la paralysie
alors tout ça avec mon expérience je
voudrais qu'on parle à un tout petit peu
de choix du confinement complet du pays
avant d'en venir à l'économie parce
qu'en fait vous êtes très en colère
contre contre cette décision vous
parlait même d'un munich sanitaire
sociale je vais vous faire écouter
arnaud fontanet de l'institut pasteur
est un professeur qui était auditionné
dans le cadre de la commission d'
enquête parlementaire qui a expliqué
qu'au fond on n'avait pas le choix
alors le confinement à la date où
effectivement la décision a été prise on
n'avait pas le choix des éléments tirés
de modèles mathématiques qui nous
laissait entendre qu'on était sur un
démarrage d'une courbe exponentielle et
que si on projetait à quelques jours
voire semaines nos estimations on se
retrouvait dans une situation où les
réanimations serait incapable de prendre
en charge des patients qu'est ce que
vous répondez à ça je comprends trop
bien faire autrement je comprends très
bien ce qui est dit et ça recoupe une
conversation qu'on a eue avec emmanuel
macron qu est la suivante vers le 10
mars le conseil scientifique que tout
juste en place vers le 10 12 pas
le conseil ce défi qu'est ce qui fait il
est paniqué et se tourner vers l'un
perial college de même que l'institut
pasteur qui reprend les chiffres de neil
ferguson
neil ferguson qui est un mot les
modélisateurs très connu et très
reconnue qui dit oh la la france cinq
cent mille cinq cent mille morts et la
panique à bord
matignon l'elysée et vous auriez fait
pareil à distance n'est mort attend des
possibles et j'explique d'abord la lexus
pu aller je vais vous expliquer pourquoi
je l'aurais pas fait pareil cinq cent
mille morts et là ils disent il faut
lisser la courbe on n'a pas les lits de
réanimation ayant ne pas envie de devoir
en france qui se passe en italie sur le
20h avec les gens qui meurent n'en lis
dans les couloirs voilà est derrière
tout ça il ya encore évidemment l'idée
du risque pénal donc on en ferme tout le
monde comme ça la question se pose même
pas moi je pense que ce fut une erreur
je suis pas le seul à le penser à de
plus en plus de gens qui pensent comme
ils le disent après le confinement des
facile j'ai écrit ce livre tout début du
confinement en en me disant la chose
suivante mais quelqu'un propos de bon
sens suspens il aurait fallu faire le
confinement qu'on a fait de confinement
ils ont tenu compte de leur erreur serre
ils ont fait un du confinement ciblées
avec la carte rouge la carte verte des
100 km il fallait faire la même chose
pour le confinement sert un confinement
ciblées il ya beaucoup de gens qui l'ont
dit un journaliste quatremer dans
libération que des régions et tous
débuts confinement ciblée sur les zones
à risque avec un périmètre sanitaires on
avait la possibilité de le faire au
début et ensuite un confinement ciblées
sur les personnes à risque de décrocher
en expliquant son président alors disons
stop alors c'est exactement ce que j'ai
fait
dès le début parce que quand moi j'ai
entendu parler d enfin j'ai vu une bande
passante sur les chaînes d'un four en
disant voilà tout le spectacle où tout
va être fermé c'est à tout l'été j'ai
paniqué donc j'ai appelé président il
s'agit je comprends pour que vous faites
pas un confinement cibler alors c'était
non seulement un confinement généralisée
erreur et non pas confinement ciblées
mais on est en plus très strict c'est
vrai que cette fameuse attestation
dérogatoire et on oublie aux nécessités
de la vue de l'esprit qu'est ce qui vous
répond le président enfin voilà et c'est
là qu'ils vous disent joker pourquoi
joker pour remplacer aussi donc on sait
que c'est dans le contexte c'est à dire
que à l'époque on n'a ni masque ni test
seulement donc pour pouvoir cibler c'est
ce qui manquait terriblement à l'état à
noter que sur la population et le masque
et les tests pour pouvoir cibler
effectivement les clusters et les zones
là pour la musique
donc non mais je n'étais pas sûr de lui
sur cette question est la preuve
d'ailleurs il a donné des instructions
pour le doute
oui de confirmer alors la preuve qu'ils
doutent je vous la donne tuc en fait à
ce moment il a une tentation c'est la
même que les parlementaires en quarante
équipes vote des pleins pouvoirs au
maréchal delfraissy seriez dit je
m'emmerde pas c'est le conseil
scientifique et là pendant plusieurs
interventions il dit nous nous en
remettons au rationnel scientifique de
même que monsieur véran ceylac tout à
coup on a vu le biopouvoir se mettre en
place et scientifique et puis sert qu'il
ya une sorte de transfert au conseil
scientifique
d'ailleurs c'est intéressant si vous
permettez juste une petite parenthèse
puisqu'on est à l'assemblée nationale la
démocratie représentative là elle éleva
si deux fois d'un côté il ya la
tentation de s'en remettre aux experts
pour le pouvoir et d'autres côtés seront
honnêtes au tirage au sort
hier les experts c'est ceux qui sont
plus compétentes nous et des tirages au
sort ceux qui sont moins compétents
après
yorick que la démocratie repose sur les
mains ça c'est un signe de maladie
démocratique
ça veut dire que quand il ne s'assument
plus quand le pouvoir ne s'assument plus
le pouvoir n'est plus pouvoir alors on a
compris
le diagnostic est le constat qui est
accablant que vous faites dans votre
livre et en même temps vous d'expliquer
que vous aviez raison depuis le début et
que c'est très bien qu emmanuel macron
au fond se convertissent à
l'indépendance à la souveraineté la
souveraineté stratégique
encore faut-il que ce soit possible
raphaël legendre ce mot des
relocalisations revient en permanence
maintenant dans la bouche des différents
ministres que ce soit celui de
l'économie le premier ministre également
qu'est-ce qu'on fait concrètement elle
voulait possible de reprendre la main le
contrôle sur nos biens stratégie ça a
servi aussi dans la bouche du président
saleh lors du déplacement à sanofi le 16
juin
emmanuel macron a indiqué que les
relocalisations c'était le premier axe
pour retrouver notre souveraineté
alors est-ce que c'est facile je vous
dis tout de suite non est ce que c'est
moi j'irais même plus loin est ce que
c'est souhaitable je ne le pense pas non
plus je prends un exemple très simple
chez sanofi emmanuel macron a parlé du
paracétamol le paracétamol qui a manqué
on a cru qu'il pourrait manquer en tout
cas pendant la crise sanitaire faut
savoir qu'aujourd'hui toute la
production du principe actif est
produite soit en chine majoritairement
80 % en inde ou au brésil
emmanuel macron le 16 juin indique dans
trois ans nous relocalisons la
production de paracétamol en france
cocorico nous aurons du doliprane
madeinfrance en 2023 c'est très bien
sauf que ça pose deux questions
d'abord est-ce que l'industrie
pharmaceutique l'avenir de l'industrie
pharmaceutique se trouve dans la vente
de paracétamol ou la valeur ajoutée est
extrêmement faible
je ne suis pas sûr et la deuxième c'est
la question du coup une boîte de
paracétamol
c'est un neuro 40 de production en chine
ces 4 euros en france c'est trois fois
plus cher donc il faut bien expliquer
aux français que les relocalisations en
coûtera plus cher à une augmentation du
coût de la vie et ce qui est vrai pour
le médicament est vrai pour l'ensemble
de l'année
ajouter qu'on pourrait relocaliser
question là ce que vous venez de dire
est très intéressant ce que ça rejoint
les débats qui ont eu lieu ici au moment
de du traité de marrakech sur l'om c'est
quelques mois après le traité de
maastricht
à l'époque on disait voilà on va
privilégier la consommation sur le
travail et on a fait le choix je me
souviens très bien une discussion et
qu'edouard balladur qui lui on va perdre
notre culture on va perdre notre
industrie mais on va regagner sur le
tertiaire parce que c'est pas demain la
veille que les chinois et les indiens
auront des ingénieurs et des
laboratoires
énorme erreur énorme erreur et donc ce
que vous évoquez effectivement c'est
très intéressant
on a fait le choix du consumérisme
mondialisé et on a une industrie qui ne
pèse plus que 10 % de notre pib contre
20% avec l'allemagne et quand vous avez
perdu votre culture livré au processus
agrochimique et que vous avez perdu
votre industrie vous installer ce qu'on
appelle des fameuses chaînes de valeur
globale
alors maintenant si sylvain deschênes
valeur globale
vous venez de les évoquer chen valeur
globale ça consiste à faire le principe
actif en inde puis l'enveloppement en
chine puis après on revient en pologne
pour etc
avant d'arriver dans la pharmacie était
bon mais les chaînes valeur globale ça
marche un temps il ya un moment donné où
l'esclave d'esclaves payer encore moins
cher parce qu'on trouve toujours un
esclave encore plus esclave d'une escale
en dehors il vient il devient le maître
et il vous dit maintenant ça suffit
le bal finissent par vous enchaînez en
d'autres termes en d'autres termes pour
les biens stratégiques alors après on
peut discuter alors c'est autre chose
effectivement parce que cette chaîne de
production globale elle a permis de
sentir des de sortir des centaines de
millions d'asiatiques notamment de la
pauvreté c'est ce qui a permis la
croissance mondiale qui fait qu'il ya
beaucoup moins de pauvreté ce qu'on
disait le problème de ces chaînes wii
vous regrettez vous permettez je réponde
là dessus sur le
en 10 avec jimmy goldsmith ici même en
1992 1994 et philippe seguin charles
pasqua
la mondialisation c'est un système dans
lequel sont les pauvres des pays riches
qui subventionne les riches des pays
pauvres et donc en fait aujourd'hui on
est dans une situation d'appauvrissement
du pays la mondialisation heureuse un
nombre de nations les chances c'est
vieux comme les phéniciens et n'en est
pas question
mais simplement un monde de nation
c'est-à-dire le carré magique de qu'on a
vu de la survie c'est à dire la
frontière la souveraineté la dépense ses
intérêts vitaux de gaulle quand il a
quand il est rentré dans le marché
commun en arrivant en 58 il a dit moi je
veux bien le marché commun à deux
conditions
d'abord la protection des intérêts
vitaux et deuxièmement la préférence
communautaire donc par exemple si on
faisait des chaînes de valeur globale
j'ai pensé vous aviez chuter là dessus
des chênes verts avec la préférence
communautaire céréales européennes on
faisait pas pour faire ses vrais
médicaments une souveraineté européenne
sera dinde relatant la suivante 1 ce
partage pas la souveraineté moitié
enceinte la souveraineté elle est une
des formes à la bonicel je parle de la
de l'autonomie stratégique l'europe
notre concept mais l'un des membres a
conclu cissé des secteurs importants
comme l'environnement l'énergie
exactement la batterie par exemple
exactement aux états unis cinq secteurs
stratégiques
voilà et donc en france on n'a plus rien
on avait ça du temps du général de
gaulle on avait de se définir je définis
peut intervenir des intérêts
stratégiques des secteurs pression on va
s'arrêter là parce que on aurait pu
continuer quand beaucoup de très
longtemps c'est passionnant les gaulois
réfractaires demande des comptes au
nouveau monde je signale au passage que
vous êtes déjà numéro un des ventes en
librairie comme d'habitude philippe
d'olivier vous restez avec nous merci à
tous d'aller macron c'était quand la
dernière fois vous devez parler au
téléphone c'était quand attention aux
yeux car on n'a droit qu'à un joker
ah j'ai plein de trucs arrêté c'était le
passé au palais-bourbon ces dernières 24
heures c'est l'heure de ma journée à
l'assemblée avec thomas des prêts thomas
qui va nous parler des directeurs
d'école ce soir les députés voulait leur
donner plus d'autonomie
finalement ça ne s'est pas fait c'est ça
thomas oui exactement myriam les députés
ont examiné hier une proposition de loi
de la république en marche créant
officiellement la fonction de directeur
d école
mais les débats laisse un goût
d'inachevé je vous raconte tout ça alors
ça c'est passé le tard hier soir dans
l'hémicycle les députés ont adopté une
proposition de loi de la majorité visant
à créer un statut pour les directeurs et
directrices d'école une proposition pour
jean michel blanquer requis permet aussi
de rendre hommage à ceux qui ont été en
seconde ligne pendant l'épidémie
nos directeurs d'école ou leur devons
dans la loi la reconnaissance des
spécificités de leur mission et nous
leur devons dans la pratique
l'amélioration de leurs conditions
d'exercice au delà du contexte actuel
donc cette proposition elle avait quatre
objectifs la revalorisation la
simplification la reconnaissance et le
soutien pour tous les directeurs des
écoles etc la députée c'est sillery lac
de la république en marche qui était à
la tribune pour présenter son projet le
statu quo n'est plus possible pour les
directeurs d'école la proposition de loi
que je porte devant vous avec mes
collègues de la majorité vise
modestement à améliorer leur situation
sur le terrain nous souhaitons
reconnaître une fonction pleine et
entière à l'heure initialement ce texte
comporter des dispositions salué dans
tous les bancs de l'hémicycle une
bonification des indemnités des
directeurs une décharge totale
d'enseignement pour les directeurs
d'école de plus de 8 classes des
dispositions ambitieuse mais qui ont été
modifiées par les députés de la majorité
sur demande du gouvernement
renvoyée à plus tard par des décrets du
ministre de l'éducation pourquoi faire
une ppl qui est en fait une coquille
vide
c'était une vraie demande vraiment de
toute la communauté éducative et s'est
réduit à néant puisque tout pouvait être
tout va passer par le réglementaire
d'habitude c'est l'épée pld
des opposants et puis là pour le coup
c'est un texte porté par la majorité on
n'a pas bien compris le jeu du
gouvernement qui a effectivement vie d
une grande partie de ce contenu
bonjour c'est cyril ac bonjour temps des
prêts les députés de l'opposition à
droite comme à gauche disent que votre
texte a été vidé de sa substance par le
gouvernement ils ont raison non je ne
suis pas d'accord avec cela puisque les
avancées principal demeure dans le tech
le but de cette proposition le rac et la
reconnaissance de la fonction des
directrices et directeurs d'école et
biens les atteintes
aujourd'hui nous avons un emploi de
direction qui va être créée alors la
frustration elle vient du fait que je
suis parlementaire et quant aux
parlementaires dans les textes de losne
d'une révision auprès des grands
principes et ensuite eh bien c'est bien
l'administration c'est bien ensuite le
ministre et les organisations syndicales
qui participent à la rédaction et des et
créé après des dispositions un petit peu
plus fine
est ce que ça veut dire que vous allez
garder le gouvernement à l'oeil a bien
évidemment ça il est hors de question
qu'on lâche je n'ai pas lâché depuis
depuis trois ans c'est pas pour lâché
dans la dernière ligne droite
voilà meriem pour être tout à fait
complet dans ce texte il ya également
une disposition qui vise à apporter
l'aide de l'état et des collectivités
locales financièrement lorsque les
directeurs d'école en ont besoin pour
accomplir au mieux leurs tâches
administratives et matériels prochaine
étape pour ce texte au sénat donc puis
la publication de ces fameux décret par
le ministère de l'éducation nationale
mais d'ici là on aura sans aucun doute
l'occasion d'en reparler dans ma journée
à l'assemblée
bonsoir camille saféris world désir de
vous retrouvez cette chronique du jeudi
de file déconfinement alors vous nous
emmenez cette semaine au café néons
comme d'habitude avec un député qui nous
fait vous découvrir et bien eu ce soir
comme je savais que nous recevions
monsieur de villiers j'ai pensé à faire
une spéciale truc à dire et j'ai trouvé
que c'était peut-être expliquer alors
qu'on a appris qu'il élève voilà alors
et à la truffe
oui voilà alors j'ai bu l'apéro avec
jean pierre cubertafon il est député
modem de dordogne et il est très sympa
très gourmand très court mais il
ressemble un peu à jean pierre coffe il
appelait les lunettes vous allez voir
comment est il est très attaché à son
terroir
il est président du groupe d'étude de la
truffe et des trufficulteurs à
l'assemblée nationale oui ça existe
alors là prenait évidemment par lui
poser la question qui s'imposait y at il
des truffes à l'assemblée à illies à 39
mais il arrive qu'il y ait en mai
lorsqu'on les apports vous aider non non
je vous donnerai pas de noms mais il
nous est arrivé de dans un petit moment
de déprime d'avoir toujours un petit
stock au restaurant du viiie est et nous
fait une petite omelette aux truffes
ah c'est vrai voilà il faut pas le dire
faut pas le dire neuf mais vous vous
lavez faire bien le soir on s'est
retrouvé avec quelques amis députés et
le chef a eu la gentillesse de nous
faire une omelette aux truffes
il a fourni les eaux il a fourni les et
puis le tour de vin et le tournoi c'est
pas facile à faire une omelette
j'apprends des choses alors fois
justement maintenant qu'on sait ça 1
quelle est la recette selon jean pierre
cubertafon d'une bonne omelette aux
truffes des oeufs des trucs pas c'est ma
femme qui les fait donc je ne peux pas
vous donner la recette qu'aucune recette
qui est totalement secrète et familiale
parfois il faut des oeufs et il faut
mettre les oeufs la veille ou l'avant
veille avec les truffes déjà la truffe
parfume les oeufs et vous avez déjà
gagné 20 ou 30% de 2 da ros alors le
truc vous la tranchée en vie il faut
qu'elle soit un peu modifié c'est un
petit peu humidifié et ensuite vous
faites votre omelette le goût garder une
ou deux tranches truffe pour mettre sur
votre emblème donc vous battez vos yeux
ouais vous mettez vos temps je truffe et
vous faites une omelette c'est pas
difficile à faire vous pourrez le faire
ce soir
alors figurez vous que jean pierre
cubertafon m'a révélé qu'à l'elysée dans
les jardins il n'y avait pas encore de
chênes truffiers
alors du coup avec lors d'une visite du
président de la république en périgord
eh bien on lui on lui en a offert un qui
a été planté à 50 m 2
entrée des appartements présidentiels il
y avait un double objectif
l'objectif de faire parler de la truffe
d'être présenté à paris mais aussi vous
savez pour être récupéré des trucs qu'il
faut cinq six ans donc dans la mesure où
on a planté en 2000
il faudrait un deuxième quinquennat j'ai
d'ailleurs dit au président en plantes
celle en tant que chaîne mais on veut
venir récupérer
voilà donc ce sera en 2023 2024 et si
c'est bon de vous annoncer que le
président se représente pas puisque le
chêne truffier est à l'elysée et qu'il
faut qu'il récupère cette puce pour le
lui a offert à lui dire merci
vous vous dire ajouter quelque chose
rapidement parce que l'émission s'achève
en fait un jour il ya un homme politique
chevronné qui m'a dit tu sais fait pour
faire un homme politique il faut être un
chien truffier et un chien d'avalanche
le chien truffier pour sentir les choses
favorable les truffes et un chien
d'avalanche pour sortir la merde
et ben voilà on va s'arrêter là merci
infiniment on aurait pu continuer
longtemps cette conversation les gaudois
réfractaires demande des comptes au
nouveau monde c'est chez fayard merci
messieurs et a très vite à mardi
prochain très belle soirée sur lcp
[Musique]